i don't think these commercial
properties are going to do well at all
in fact i think they're going to lose
a substantial portion of their value
over the next six months per year
we have companies where sales are down
but cash flow is up now how did that
happen
and he's working alone as i went in for
my coffee today i said hey where
where are your employees he said i can't
get them to come back making more money
on unemployment
so kevin what's going on where are you
located right now you're at you're i'm
i'm
at a lake i'm at a lake in canada that's
right i'm going to spend a couple of
weeks here
i just left florida barbara which was
crazy
as you can imagine just crazy i almost
lost you there i was there for four
months i'm sorry
i was there for four months and um it
was really nuts
and it opened up then it closed down and
it opened up and it closed down and when
i left it was closing down again to to a
bigger close down than it
ever was no walking rights and all kinds
of surprises
i think they're doing the right thing
because they got to nip this thing in
the bud like other countries have done
and i think it's
a little slow would you say that florida
is probably our best example of a
slow on the draw so to speak yeah i'm
getting notifications every day from my
building and they say they're now
testing twenty percent positive for
everybody
wow that's amazing so you got out of
there at the nick of time but you
you and your wife are healthy right your
children and i did the whole test thing
anyways and everything else
but i was just listening to you talking
about real estate i'm fascinated about
that because
um i'm just wondering because you're a
real estate person barbara
what's going to happen to triple a
office towers you know i own some of
them
through reits if people don't feel safe
going up those elevators to the 70th and
80th floor what's
i mean what are the values going on i'll
tell you what's going on in new york
city it's not just the elevators nobody
wants to get in a crowded elevator but
long before they hit the elevator no one
wants to commute to work
they don't want to jump on the subway
they don't want to sit in a car for two
hours and they've had the unusual
opportunity
that they were allowed to work at home
and people are
loving it i think it's going to be a
tall order to get people back to the
workplace as
we knew it before and i don't think it's
going to happen i know there's a new
movement here in new york city
where teams of people are coming in like
your marketing department comes in one
day
the next day your research department
comes in so they're rotating people
which means
less desks are needed and what's
concurrent with that is
every landlord in town is hearing from
every tenant
they're renegotiating leases even if
they have five or ten years left on the
lease
everybody is holding back on rent we're
going to see a bloodbath i'm sorry to
tell you
if you've been well invested in reits i
don't think these commercial properties
are going to do well at all in fact i
think they're going to lose
a substantial portion of their value
over the next six months to a year
so can you get out is my question yeah i
have i've reduced my exposure from
almost 30 percent down to eight
and i've also sold all the regional
banks and the money center banks that
own the mortgages
um obviously i took some losses but
they've gone down
significantly further since so clearly
the market is figuring what
what you're saying i'm just wondering is
the impairment can be 25 35
what do you think two or three years
from now a building that used to sell
for 100 million is going to sell for
30 off i had a guest but you know what
guesses are they depend on the future
but i would say from where i sit there
30 off yeah but that's not the real
problem the real problem is who's going
to want to buy them
i don't think a lot of people are going
to have an appetite for that even at
that steep discount
wow well and just just before we leave
real estate what about i heard you
mentioned
wait wait wait wait wait kevin hold on a
minute hold on i'm interviewing you
you're not interviewing me
well i figured if i can look if i can
learn something while i'm talking he
would get some value out of you barb
it's the first time it's ever happened
that would be great
that's my kevin just quickly on condos
in new york because you know i am
shopping around
by now or wait oh kevin you're not going
to buy anything you've been shopping
around for four years you're too cheap
to spend the money
i want to buy your condo barbara i want
your time 50 you wouldn't open that
wallet i know you you're too cheap
why can't i kick you out of your place
i'll take your place i like it my place
is beautiful but i would never move out
you'll have to take me out in a cough
and i'm afraid yeah
yeah if you want to spend if you want to
spend a lot of money right now on a
brand new condominium on a serious dough
which
again i'd say you never will um you
could get
substantial kid discounting already to
the 20 25
if you work directly with the developers
they don't admit they're discounting but
any deals that are happening which are
so few are steeply discounted
the reason people don't know how bad
that market is because many of the
developers are built for the future
so they can't close yet but when you see
those closing prices
roll out you're going to say to me
barbara i should have listened to
i should have bought back then because
now look what i have to pay now
but you won't buy then well my problem
is
i don't want to live i don't want to
live in hotels anymore when i go to new
york when things get back to normal
whatever they're going to be
because i just i don't want hotels but i
don't want to be around
yeah you've been saying that for years
you're going to stay in the hotel
because you don't want to put the money
out let's move on from right here if i
catch a cold blogger i'm blaming you
again kevin let me ask you a question
what advice have you been giving your
entrepreneurs we both invested a lot of
businesses
some do so much better than others some
are dead on arrival
some we're questioning all the time but
nonetheless we're in the position of
of an advisor an investor what advice
overall have you been giving your
investments as to what they should have
been doing and still should be doing
through this pandemic i'm curious
because i want to steal that advice if
it's any good
well the ones that have been successful
you know i've got some that are involved
in industries like the wedding industry
which has been decimated and i've got
summer in restaurants which has been
killed
but the ones that are selling goods and
services that have really been
successful
and i just this morning got off the
phone with two of them
have basically set up shopify uh
platforms
they are lots of their products been
kicked out of retail or they're not
selling retail anymore so they've gone
directly to their customers
now here's the thing to note barbara
this is what shocked me today
if you were selling uh well you'll find
this interesting
we have companies where sales are down
but cash flow is up now how did that
happen
instead of paying 50 percent to
retailers and distributors they've sold
direct to customers
they've been able to capture back at
full margin
so you look at the success of a love pop
greeting cards which was 50
in in retail which is now basically
all online at full margin they're just
killing it
yes of course i'm sorry go ahead yes and
i have another one uh bertucci uh pizza
ovens
a deal i closed very recently um
it's one of those rare deals where
because of everybody staying at home
sales are 400 percent ahead of schedule
i've actually made all my money back on
that deal it's only been five months
wow that's terrific what are you going
to advise them as uh things
return slowly to normal they're not
going to be selling that many pizza
ovens anymore
maybe but what i've been able to do with
them as i said if people are willing to
buy these pizza ovens
we need more direct to consumers so this
morning i i just got a deal with um
qvc we're going live on the early august
we're going to sell a
huge amount online and i think you know
you've got to make hay while the sun is
shining on some of this
these situations and and for me the
direct to consumer is not going away i
don't think this trend
is going to stop we're not going to sell
as many ovens to retail anymore because
we have to give up 40 percent margin
barbara i don't want to do that
sell direct and the consumer also gets
accustomed to a lower price
uh you're very familiar with my most
successful deal from two years ago the
comfy
which is an oversized sweatshirt uh they
were in a pickle the minute the pandemic
hit
they couldn't sell through the stores
they had almost 30 million dollars in
merchandise and stores that closed up
they got all that merchandise back they
didn't know what to do
and exactly what you said they sold
direct to the consumer and they've
almost doubled their sales
i really prayed for the most nights
saying are they going to go down they're
in trouble
now they just turned right on their
heels and
slammed at home on the internet and
they've been selling twice as many
coffees go figure it out so yes i don't
think that's the trend that's going to
go away i hold hardly
so the pivot to direct to consumer is a
worldwide phenomenon and i think you
know when we get back to shooting shark
tank
whenever that happens we're going to see
a ton of deals
that are focused on doing just that the
old distribution model is going to
change
i think it's going to be more efficient
i don't think retail is going to ever
look the same
as what it used to i think there's all
kinds of malls across america that are
going to be changed into cloud kitchens
or
inventory for climate control for direct
distribution who knows
but wow what a change it happened real
fast do you think on shark tank you're
going to shop with that in mind like put
your entire focus on
those businesses that are direct to
consumer and not invest in anything that
is not because i'm sure we'll see our
share of
various kinds of businesses as we always
do well if your strategy is all retail
i'm going to pay a big discount for that
because that's riskier than anything
today
because i'm not sure that all right look
at all the bankruptcies neiman marcus
who could have even thought they'd go
bankrupt
they're worthless now worthless and so
and if you are selling through there
you're probably going to wait
months to get your inventory back and
all the rest of that stuff i think at
the end of the day
yes i am going to look for companies
that are going to do better online that
have the savvy
social media skills to tap that versus
ones that just tell me oh let's go sell
through retail that's what i think yeah
well i could hear your picture already
i'm sorry
uh you'll be talking to one entrepreneur
after another and insulting them with a
low bid
and using that excuse again and again
you always come up with an excuse to pay
very little and to beat those poor
entrepreneurs into the ground and for
those people who are listening
give me a feedback on that what do you
think about the way kevin
beats up on these entrepreneurs it
breaks my heart you know at times i'm
sitting on the set you don't see it on
the camera
i'm crying my eyes out i'm breaking
listen barbara
let's tell the truth because where we
have to be honest there's a reason they
call me mr wonderful there's no false
advertising here
okay yeah that's false advertising
moving on from that of course
hey listen what uh what do you think
other than direct to consumer are the
big opportunities out there right now
because we have a
huge audience of young entrepreneurs
struggling some people moving ahead
but what do you think are the big
opportunities for young entrepreneurs to
take advantage of right now other than
direct to consumer
two areas that i want to focus on in and
outside of shark tank
number one is health care i think people
are going to be very very focused on
going on health and i'm fascinated
by better food groups i think people are
now having been locked at home
and doing so much cooking on their own
or fascinated by food options
and i want to get into foods that are
healthy uh sustainable
good to eat and i've been cooking like a
banji myself
chef wonderful gotta see oh yeah of
course chef wonderful has been a
flower that's been blooming just a chef
boyardee
what i hope we see is a whole lot of
health initiatives
things that help people live a healthier
life
i'm not saying just exercise equipment
i'm talking about you know maybe
more deals like blue land the thing i
did with the disinfectants and detergent
was crystallized that was a big success
for me
there's another one barbara that was a
big rollout if you recall they were
having they were going to do a giant
retail rollout
okay we were just i'm gonna push you one
moment again kevin just for the sake of
the people who are listening
whatever kevin's saying cut right in
half he grossly exaggerates his
successes and he buries his failures
keep going kevin
so let me tell you this is twice as
successful as i thought it was going to
be and you're full of
and you know barbara you are so full of
poo poo it's ridiculous the only reason
barbara i want everybody to know that's
here no don't do it
yes the only reason barbara is where
she's at is i bought her a new broom
that's how she got
now barbara let me tell you the story of
blue land talk about a pivot
wonderful woman entrepreneur she was
facing a complete
complete shutdown of her sales because
all of it was set to go into big box
retailers
she pivoted she bought remnant cable
time on comcast
and she and i made a commercial for her
and she made several others and all we
did was sell direct at full margin
she is way ahead of budget and she
hasn't sold anything for the retail
well you know she had to put that money
out and take that risk she deserves
success
something new yeah buys detergent online
now everybody's doing it that's the
whole thing of course well it's
delivered to your door not a bad thing
and it's done quickly as well right
yes exactly are you ready to take some
questions from our
adoring audience absolutely wait to ask
your questions
let's go let's see what we got i have
like quite a few good ones coming and
keep them coming in
okay and the first one is can oh can my
boss make me go back to work
if i don't oh hold on look at that
barbara i'm back
it depends it depends what states you're
in some of those are state mandates
some of them are municipal and county
mandates
there's no federal mandate that
determines whether you can go back to
work or shouldn't
this is determined by where you're at
because right now in florida
i don't think anybody with that has
their head screwed on right is asking
you to go back
to an office when 20 of the people
walking around are testing positive
so dave county is effectively shut down
that's a good example
and there's other places like vermont
and even boston now where people are
going back to the office because they
feel safe
depends on the region well kevin this is
for marian in florida i realized miami
actually where you just left
what about there no way to force her
back right no
no in fact um in our in our uh building
where we hire 21 people
we've had you know and i'm obviously
close with them we've had several
meetings about
people's comfort and we've gone to a
full n95 mass protocol
everybody in the building outside of
their unit has to wear that mask
and and gloves and uh they come in
voluntarily to work if they come in they
get paid
and so um and they're all coming in
because we have a really super safe
protocol
there's a there's another question
that's so similar it's probably the
other side of that
which is uh if i go back to work and i'm
not comfortable
must i wait it's not really worded well
but
basically the question is can my boss
insist i stay if i'm not comfortable
good question you know i'm i telling
everybody
nobody is going to sue you for taking
care of yourself
and if you're not comfortable do what
your heart says
because you do not want to contract this
virus it's coming out
clearly in the press lately that it's
not a respiratory disease it's a blood
disease
it's affecting people's organs it's
affecting their heart rates it's
affecting their oxygen intake
this is a nasty bug and we don't want to
get it just do what you think is safe
and don't be foolish i mean wear a mask
look at the countries that have got out
of trouble switzerland
8 million people only 14 cases
everybody wears a mask i don't know why
we're not doing that we're nuts
oh we don't particularly have people
leading us in that direction i don't
think either do we
let's get let's not get into politics no
we're not going to get into politics
i'll leave that out
as i always do um i i ran into a
shopkeeper this morning has a little
bistro on madison avenue a tiny little
shop
guy has three employees uh and he's
working alone as i went in for my coffee
today i said hey where
where are your employees he said i can't
get them to come back to making more
money on unemployment
than coming back to work he said so i'm
working the shop myself he had a line of
people
that he couldn't keep up with what do
you say to a guy like that yeah i
actually have some companies that said
that's happening to us in my shark tank
portfolio
80 of my companies qualified for the ppp
and got it
and the 20 that didn't get it didn't
have their accounting and payroll
records
um up to up to date so that's a new
policy i'm going to make a change on
everybody's going to have to get an
accountant
before i close a deal because that was a
big loser but
what i learned is this this person is
absolutely right
um in states like california like new
york
like florida and texas the unemployment
is better
than working and we've got to fix that
immediately because that's kind of
stupid that's counterproductive
the ppp money was to to give them uh
and maintain their jobs and we're
finding they won't even come in because
the unemployment's a better deal
what's your advice to that guy my advice
to him would be to go back to work
go back to work take the job because at
some point
that whole unemployment game is going to
be over and he'll be without a job
he should keep his memory um intact with
his boss and his infrastructure
work safely obviously maybe remotely the
dis the difference
is about 11 barbara between which is a
lot i understand
you're 11 percent better off with the
unemployment than the
ppp but with the ppp you have a job
you're actually employed so you might
have other benefits like medical
and other and dental insurance and
things like that it's really confusing
me too many numbers i'm getting a
headache just listening
basically basically take the job if you
get if you can get it
that's what i say well you know what i'm
going to what i said to the boss and i'm
going to share your advice but i think
he's already going to be taking mine by
tonight
i said to him call your three employees
and tell them as of monday
they're going to be replaced if they
don't want to come back he said i'll do
that
i'll let you know on monday what happens
and they call me the nasty one look at
you barbara
no i mean you just have to size you have
to give a deadline i think
oh boy that's nasty okay one last one i
just graduated from college
and i'm really worried about the job
market how do i stand out for the
millions of people looking for work now
good one oh listen i've had i've been
asked that question by the way it's a
good chance for me to promote
my ask myself don't promote just answer
them no no
because i answer this question every
week on ask mr wonderful my youtube
channel and i'm definitely promoting it
barbara
why would i do this why would i do this
for free for you unless i'm promoting
something
are you kidding but anyways the answer
that question is interesting because
i've had lots of
results from this now having been doing
it for five months
write a letter no more than three
paragraphs
explaining why you can help that person
that you want to get a job at get their
job done
faster and ask to work for 90 days for
free for nothing in an apprentice or
internship
position just getting in the door is
ninety percent of the challenge
if you deliver any value during those
ninety days you will get an employment
you will get a job
because right now businesses are
freaking out trying to figure
to do things like how do i get online
how do i deal with social media how do i
communicate directly with customers
if you're young and you know how to use
social media that's a skill that many
companies that are old school
are trying to hire for but they don't
know how to do it
and so you're willing to go do it for
free for 90 days
you take over their social media you
show you can how you can acquire
customers economically
bang you're gonna have a job i see okay
well i'm gonna
listen to that advice and share it and
make it my own say i came up with the
idea what do you think about that
well barbara i'll show you immediately
that'll be good press
you might know too that the job boards
have gone up by almost 35
in the last week alone so the number of
job postings has skyrocketed
and of course all all types of
businesses so there are many many people
hiring right now i think it's almost the
rumor out there is there's no jobs no
jobs and you know
better than most kevin that whatever's
in your head your own attitude what you
envision
kind of comes true so if you kind of
think instead there's lots of jobs how
do i get the job versus it's not much
going on
it's a much better posture to shoot from
don't you think
yeah i agree but you you mentioned the
platforms that the number one growth
platform
in terms of activity right now is
linkedin
make sure you have your linkedin page
you know as they say oh courant
in other words go groom it and the other
thing i keep telling people about that
you
the whole linkedin thing less is more no
one's going to read 15 pages about where
you went to high school in the name of
your dog no one gives a [ __ ]
put down what you can do to help an
employer be more efficient
and there's so much demand around
digital around social media around
direct to consumer around skill sets on
facebook
or shopify or any of these platforms
people are screaming for employees that
know how to work that stuff
what would you say to people who are
just a last question i know i promise
you the last one was the last here's one
more
i'm making this one up but it's a it's a
it's a theme that runs through so many
of the questions i get
how do i keep my attitude up and ready
how do i keep myself above water how do
i keep myself
optimistic i'm starting to feel
depressed
that kind of thing how does somebody get
themselves up
you know mr wonderful what do you say
yeah you know i have lots of employees
i've talked to this about because they
have been working remotely now for
almost five and a half months in some
cases in very small
condos and apartments um
that's tough to do after a while i mean
you know and if they're single and
things like that
the number one thing is not to run out
of money um you get
if you want to really get depressed get
to a place where you're basically
bankrupt because then
people run out of money yeah i know but
the thing is
most people i found because now it's a
real life situation
are able to cut their expenditures by 30
percent even 35
even 40 by just buying the essentials
many people have stopped paying rent you
mentioned that earlier that's
true landlords are being flexible
because they can't sue every one of
their tenants
but you have to be careful that it
doesn't trash your credit rating going
forward
it's better to notify the landlord that
you've lost your job
than to surprise them by not paying them
most of them are willing to take
less when you're when you're forward
about it but and the other thing i keep
telling them is
this is a chance in your life to reflect
on things read the book you've always
wanted to
find a hobby that you know learn how to
play guitar or an instrument
try do the photography you bought the
camera for that you've never picked up
whatever that is you've got to find
something to do with your your idle time
or you'll just go nuts
those are the things i recommend those
are the left brain kind of things that i
would
hope you would recommend because you
think so
so cleanly on all those types of issues
i'm going to give a little uh right
brain advice here
which is i think the best thing about uh
us
all wrestling through this terrible
chapter has been it's given us pause to
evaluate who we want to be when we grow
up
i don't care what age you are it's also
given us pause
uh to to actually sit and find our own
confidences
our own confidence and most of the
people who are losing confidence right
now i find they're losing their
confidence because they're not trying
things
and yet many people think you have to
succeed to get confidence but i find
all the young people that get confidence
in themselves more than ever get it by
trying
and so i i'm a big proponent of just
trying
everything you can possibly try because
what you wind up with
as you come through this difficult
chapter with more confidence that you
went in with
and if you really want to get ahead in
life you know it kevin i know it
uh confidence often comes out of
failures and tries
but it's the confidence that keeps with
you for life look how
cocky you are i mean how did you get
that cocky not because you were
successful at everything you did i see
you do many things that you don't
succeed at
but boy oh boy do you keep coming back
and trying would you agree with my kind
of
emotional advice on that one kevin yeah
so i think that's great advice for
anybody that's feeling down
i mean you everybody has to find that
thing in life that they love doing that
they're
passionate about that they're willing to
work 25 hours a day on
and i've always said that you have to
try a lot of things before you'll find
out what that is you can't know till you
do it yes
um i'm i'm very concerned that colleges
aren't going to have
uh classrooms people together anymore
which is why they're seeing record
amounts of people moving back to the
town that their college is in even
though there's only virtual classes
because they need to be together and i
think that's important
but the number one thing barbara i think
we should leave on that i have
begun i'm not leaving on any number one
thing you're saying
i'm leaving this on the number one thing
i'm saying go ahead well i'm
i'm going to give some great advice here
barbara and then you should do exactly
what i say
as you always should you know that's the
key i mean
thank goodness i'm there on shark tank
if i let you to your own
you would lose all your money it's just
ridiculous go ahead
anyways here's the thing i've learned
from all of this
um better be good it is very good you
know there's a
you have a certain responsibility to
yourself and your family and your
friends
to start acting um safely about this
virus
it makes no sense to me anymore that
when you go outside you wouldn't wear a
mask or when you go to someone's house
you wouldn't wear a mask
i don't let anybody come here anymore
that isn't
living by that edict i have masks for
them
i don't want anybody to get sick but
i've i now know
many people that have gotten the virus
this is the difference
from five months ago and the outcomes in
some cases have been
horrific including death and so
i am now note to end on it's just it's a
positive thing that we can lick this
thing
if we all get responsible florida's in
the mess it's in because nobody was
wearing a mask
like i was practically the only guy
going shopping at fresh market with a
mask on people were looking at me like i
was a weirdo or something
now look at them yes now that now they
have to wear a mask and i think that's
the
i want to just give that note think
safely
social distance wear a mask you don't
want to get sick it's crazy
my last comment is it's a wonderful time
to start a business
um most of the most successful people i
know started
on the heels of a failure a bad chapter
because the whole world gets redefined
people are open to new ideas new
businesses new ways of doing things
so while you're listening mr wonderful
and putting your mask on
uh remember if you had a dream about
starting a business now is the time to
get it going
that's it don't say another word kevin
don't
no barbara that's such good advice i'm
gonna get you another new broom
if you like that video wait do you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe